[Music]
we need to talk about beards it's become
a bit of a trend recently some say we've
even reached peak beard Thank You
hipsters it's much more than trend
actually facial hair is one of the
oldest and boldest statement of
masculinity you can make it's also quite
practical
you can hide scar with it or facial
features that you don't like like a
receding chin but is it acceptable in
the world of business well short answer
of course it is but there are only two
acceptable styles one is this one the
classic fall beard in a variety of
lengths and shapes and the goatee and
it's many installations everything else
no don't do it are you killing me maybe
if you're planning a career in the
circus keep it neat and tidy have it
trimmed by a pro once in a while someone
like Marc over there
[Music]
all right Matt what are the biggest
mistakes well you have to keep your
throat clean-shaven and your lips need
to be free of beard so we don't want to
look like a walrus I don't want to look
like a bloody barbers and this it's not
a beard that's just badly shaved what
about a moustache No
no much better
you